rénover ou construire quinze collèges
c'est l'objectif annoncé par le
département
les travaux sont prévus entre 2023 et
2026 le but réduire de 40% l'empreinte
carbone des collèges les quinze collèges
choisissons 15 collèges qui sont des
trappes énergétique et nous allons les
reconstruire selon des normes
environnementales nouvelle c'est à dire
en utilisant des matériaux biosourcés
comme on dit aujourd'hui c'est à dire du
bois du chambre etc
le département investit 525 millions
d'euros dans le projet deuxième annonce
l'accès aux passe plus pour les jeunes
yvelinois un service interdépartemental
avec les hauts-de-seine
il est accessible collégiens et lycéens
dès la rentrée en sixième jusqu'à leur
majorité
nous allons consacrer cette année toutes
les années qui viennent 5 millions
d'euros pour proposer à 160 mille jeunes
se passe entre 80 et 100 euros qui leur
permettra d' adhérer et donc d'avoir les
services de 2000 structures sportives ou
culturelles dans le départ dans des
igloos seule condition pour avoir accès
aux passes être domiciliés ou scolarisés
dans l'un des deux départements
trois cent mille jeunes sont concernés